ici dans cette boutique versailles est
ce pas question de parler de black
friday malgré un contexte financier
compliqué et gérants n'ont jamais
pratiqué ces journées d'opération
promotionnelle depuis l'ouverture du
magasin sont les yeux ce rendez-vous ne
correspond pas à l'image de ce concept
store installé cours des senteurs sur un
pot de confiture qu'on avait fait
fabriquer il ya quelques moi de vous
dire je vais te faire 70 % de réduction
ça poserait un problème à quelqu'un soit
aux producteurs soit moi et après mon
client aussi qui pourrait se dire mais
en fait si toute l'année je paye 70%
plus chers
ce commerçant sensations de vol ou de
quelque chose qui est qui marchent pas
autre raison invoquée les problèmes de
stocks ils sont bien moins important que
dans les grosses enseignes
j'ai pas un cargo qui arrive donc kong
pour que je pouvoir vendre à une
centaine de mètres même constat dans ce
petit commerce situé rue royale à
versailles le black friday ces
promotions ne sont pas les bienvenus la
raison cette créatrice indépendante
installée dans ce magasin partage et
crée elle même ses produits estime me
vendre ses marchandises au juste prix je
calcule le temps que j'ai passé à fermer
produit par exemple à vous avez
l'exemple d'un bracelet manchette en
cuir que j'ai fait j'ai tout bien fait
mes calculs avec les matériaux avec le
temps que j'ai passé à le faire il faut
pas oublier que c'est un produit
artisanal
ce n'est pas un produit industriel il
n'a pas été fait lâche n ya pas de mots
qu'ils ont fait c'est moi qui l'ait fait
voilà donc le prix est juste et donc ya
pas de raison de faire des remises
dessus et le black friday ne devrait pas
s'installer dans les prochaines années
chez les petits commerces versailles et
ils nous ont déjà indiqué qu'il ne le
ferait pas l'année prochaine